inciso se escribe pero no evalúe es una
expresión para la integral del volumen
del sólido de revolución generado por r
esta es la región r cuando gira
alrededor de la recta horizontal y es
igual a 1 entonces vamos a poner la
recta aquí igual a 1 va a ser esta de
aquí y bueno la idea para resolver este
problema va a ser la siguiente primero
me quiero fijar qué pasa con la función
inferior es decir una función fx
si yo giro esta función alrededor de la
recta y igual a 1 alrededor de esta
recta entonces voy a obtener un sólido
de revolución y la idea es la siguiente
me voy a fijar y voy a analizar con
calma la función fx cuando quiera
alrededor de la recta e igual a 1 y
después le voy a restar el sólido de
revolución que me queda al girar la
función superior es decir la función de
x esa va a ser la idea de cómo vamos a
resolver este problema entonces
fijémonos primero en fx como sacó
estudios de revolución al cuidar fx
alrededor de la recta
y igual a uno bueno pues con el método
de los discos el método de los discos lo
habíamos visto en la sección de cálculo
en sólidos de revolución y bueno
entonces yo voy a crear un disco con
este pequeño rectángulo muy delgado que
tengo este es el radio y entonces este
pequeño rectángulo esta pequeña hebra la
voy a girar alrededor de la recta y
igual a 1 y así voy a formar un disco
entonces este va a ser mi disco
dibujemos el disco bien y este disco
tiene un cierto grosor entonces voy a
poner su grosor es su profundidad por
así decirlo esta es su profundidad bueno
de hecho creo que lo puedo dibujar un
poco mejor que esto no lo voy a borrar
porque mejor voy a dibujarlo así esta es
la profundidad o el ancho o el grosor de
este disco bien y bueno este grosor de
una vez lo voy a poner nombre este
grosor es de xy yo lo que quiero es que
este grosor sea muy pero muy delgado muy
pequeño y bueno atrás lo que vamos es el
volumen de este disco pero antes de
sacar el volumen de este disco lo
primero que necesito es sacar el área
de una de las caras de este disco y se
dan cuenta sacar el área de una de estas
caras es sacar el área de un círculo o
sea pi por radio al cuadrado pero quien
es el radio que se cuenta que el radio
de este disco es esta distancia de aquí
a camps que es más o menos que la recta
1 - la función fx el radio de este disco
es la recta igual a 1 - la función fx y
eso es lo que estamos haciendo girar por
lo tanto ya podemos sacar el área de
este disco quien va a ser el área spears
por radio al cuadrado porque es un
círculo y esto es lo mismo que pi por el
radio pero el radio vale 1
fx y todo esto lo tenemos que elevar al
cuadrado porque es el área de un círculo
ahora si lo que quiero es el volumen de
este disco pues hay que multiplicarlo
por el ancho del disco es decir por de x
muy bien pero ya tengo el volumen de uno
de los discos realmente yo lo que quiero
es el volumen del todo el sólido de
revolución y para eso lo que hacíamos
eran dos cosas importantes primero me
voy a tomar la suma de todos los demás
discos la suma de este disco también
este disco que se formaría aquí también
de este otro disco también y voy a tomar
todas las sumas de ellos y además voy a
hacer que estos discos sean
infinitamente delgados por lo tanto el
volumen va a ser igual a la suma de
todos ellos es decir la integral de
donde donde de cero a un medio de cero a
un medio de pi por la función uno menos
fx elevado al cuadrado este es el área
de uno de mis discos
este es el área de uno de mis discos y
hay que multiplicarlo por de x para que
es el volumen de uno de mis discos y
bueno al tomarme la integral de cero a
un medio estoy tomando el volumen de
todos los discos desde x igual a cero
hasta x igual a un medio muy bien por lo
tanto ya tengo el sólido de revolución
el volumen del sólido de revolución aquí
me faltaba un pequeño de equis para que
se cumpliera esta igualdad pero ya lo
tengo bueno y entonces ya tengo el
volumen de mi sólido de revolución al
girar la función f x alrededor de la
recta igual a 1 por lo tanto este
volumen es el volumen de fx muy bien
volumen subíndice efe y ahora voy a
sacar el volumen subíndice g pero se dan
cuenta es lo mismo
a la función game y la voy a hacer girar
alrededor de la recta de igual a 1 por
lo tanto también voy a obtener un sólido
de revolución y el volumen de este
sólido de revolución pues también es la
integral de cero a un medio de ese
cuenta que también la función que llega
hasta un medio de pi por 1 - gdx es casi
igual que el otro volumen es el radio
que es 17 x este radio 17 x elevado al
cuadrado porque es el área y x tx y ya
con esto tengo la suma de todos los
volúmenes de cada uno de los discos de
gm pero bueno lo que nos pide el inciso
c es una expresión para la integral que
define el volumen del sonido de
revolución generado por la región r al
girar alrededor de esta recta desde
cuenta que la región
r es más o menos que la función de x
menos la función fx por lo tanto si yo
quiero el volumen de este sólido de
revolución va a ser la diferencia de los
dos volúmenes es decir la integral de
cero medio de pi por uno menos fx
elevado al cuadrado de x menos la
integral del cero a un medio
the people 17 x todo esto elevado al
cuadrado de x lo que estoy haciendo
realmente es más ni menos que restar los
dos volúmenes el volumen del sol y de
revolución generado por efe - el volumen
del suelo de revolución generador por
ejemplo y esto lo podemos significar un
poco esto es people integral de ser un
medio de se cuenta que pies factor común
y lenta ideal para los mismos límites de
integración de 1 - f x elevado al
cuadrado menos 17 x elevado al cuadrado
y todo esto todo esto multiplicado por
de x y bueno aunque aquí ya tenemos la
expresión para esta integral podemos
sustituir a fx iag x con las funciones
que tenemos aquí arriba
fx era estar aquí gx es esta de aquí por
lo tanto vamos a ponerlo esto es lo
puedo poner como pi por la integral de
cero a un medio por la función
1 - efe x pero fx era 8 x al cubo
todo esto elevado al cuadrado menos
paréntesis uno menos seno de pi x todo
esto elevado al cuadrado
esto de equis y ya está aquí tenemos la
respuesta del inciso c y también vemos
porque no querían que tuviéramos la
molestia de evaluar y resolver está
integral